the fact that you have The Bravery to be
like yeah I do it is amazing that
you you take it because I would be
chicken I'd be like no I'm going to
start out with just a couple scenes and
if I like that and if I'm doing it I'm
managing I'll work my way up I'll build
it you're like going Prospero I'm like
Jesus Christ John but you've always had
that that attitude since I've known you
you've always been one to take risks to
try things to be creative a good scene
partner I mean I you know working with
you I I think I improved substantially
as an actor because I would learn my
lines even more because I wanted to in a
way impress you I wanted to I wanted you
to almost like a father figure like I
wanted you to be proud I wanted you to I
wanted to show John Tony Award winner
all these things I wanted to I wanted
you to like me and respect me and and
and and uh I I always put a lot of
weight on that sort of thing just
because just to make me better and it
and it did um
but I guess you don't lose that you
still have that that in you you know I
hope so well you do you do do you want
to just do you I think that
maybe you know would be good for you
maybe good for me what if we just got
into an acting class or what if we got
into something just to sharpen
our skills and start working on scenes I
did that when I was here because when I
moved out to
California and I started making
money then I would take jobs and make
money but I but I wasn't enjoying uh the
work yeah and uh and I there was a
teacher that I know a lot of people
worked with out here a man named Milton
celis um
and I thought I should go to him and I
so I asked somebody at the gym one day
that I knew that studied with him can I
go to a class and look at a class and he
asked Milton and Milton said yeah bring
him bring him bring him and so I studied
with him and and he said Milton said to
me one day he said you'd closed up shop
you'd
stopped it's like you you weren't
working anymore so he got me back to to
enjoying the work again
so see that's what that's
interesting because I think it's the
enjoyment I miss but I don't look at it
anything as enjoyment in terms of you
know acting nothing really inspires me
so I wonder if I could bring back that
element of like you remember in college
or high school when you're just reading
scenes with people or you're just
improvising or you're playing games or
tongue twisters and there was an element
of fun and my therapist told me you have
to do whatever you do there has to be an
element of fun in it or you're not going
to enjoy it so maybe that's also what I
need maybe it's some getting a teacher
like that goes let let me bring the fun
back he died oh that's not fun that's
not fun no